hey guys i'm ryan right hey guys i'm
gerry today we're gonna check out from
all-time movies 5 horror franchise that
need to die branches franchises there's
a lot of lunches no he said franchise my
bad gary is a huge fan of horror films
and I thought who's to bring around them
Jer bear let's do this thanks Jamie from
all-time movies and these are the five
horror movies with too many sequels that
should have called it quits earlier that
went to hot [ __ ] hot [ __ ] in a negative
way not good luck [ __ ] that just turn
into hot trash throttle them in the bin
Oh morning we've got some pretty
gruesome spoilers coming up so if you're
feeling squeamish or holding out for a
horror movie marathon maybe look away
now
I hate that number 5 it's the Paranormal
Activity series the films follow Katie a
young woman terrorized by paranormal
forces she gets possessed again and
again and again the full film mix it up
a bit by following Katie after her
possession diversity but we were back on
familiar ground for film 5 where we got
to see the possession we wats in the
first one all over again this time for a
slightly different camera angle
just in case we'd forgotten to bring on
the spin offs
you mean the mark 1 next up I liked is
saw did congratulations
you are still along it took an entire
decade and seven movies before Studios
finally decided to cool time on this
franchise the first full-length Saw
movie was a surprise sleeper hit raking
in 103 million dollars loved it and
critics saw it as a credible horror
thriller others dismissed it as torture
porn and with each sequel the torture
scene has just got worse and worse by
the time we retreated to soar in full 3d
glory which we don't say gory audiences
had had enough and didn't watch it
let's just hope no one decides to make a
prequel coming in at 3 is Alawis became
the original 1978 film is celebrated as
one of the best horror movies of all
time and a classic slasher film but by
film number 10 Michael Myers refusal to
die had just become ridiculous no not
not that one this one over the course of
the Halloween movies Maya survived three
stabbings four shootings a fire falling
from a window falling down a mine being
hit by a truck yeah
to date the masked murderer has managed
to kill 102 people Wow
and with so screenwriters Patrick Milton
and Marcus Dunstan you've heard of them
onboard to write yet another sequel it's
looking like that death toll is only
going to get higher
at number two is the Friday the 13th
franchise spanning three decades the 12
films have pulled out every horror movie
cliche in the book everything from the
way our villain enters a room to the
death of the couple about to get it on
and the final surviving good girl Friday
the 13th
sure does horror movies by the book and
like the best bodies he's doing it all
for his mum oh sweet finally we get to
the horror franchise that should have
pulled the plug a long a time ago how
many for the grand total of 14 that
we've been watching families move in and
out of 112 Ocean Avenue for nearly 40
years
prone to dysfunctional plumbing
mysteriously locking doors and leaking
walls the real estate agents selling
this place really do deserve a raise and
if they're not moving in themselves the
people of Amityville just can't stop
themselves from taking it's possessed
possessions into their own homes the
sixth movie introduce us to the
terrifying cursed clock ding-dong and
film the birth it brought us the
horrifying story of a haunted lamp with
another film scheduled for 2016
who knows what's going to be haunted
next so do you think we've missed any
movies from our list taxes Nightmare on
Elm Street from top well there thanks
for watching all time movies and make
sure to watch the next one you yeah the
what was the fifth one ever you got
horror no that was the first 100
Paranormal Activity is a franchises
supposedly the fifth one is going to be
the last one this would be number six oh
well yeah this is paranormal 5 let's the
ghost world or ghost don't make me
become the technical guy that's your the
shot next film it
they gave the food a subtitle and it was
in you know la or an it was an R to be
enough yeah true but it's still wrapped
into that story yeah but the real part 5
is coming out and this is true yeah I
don't know I go back and forth in those
movies cuz like I like a couple of them
the marked ones maybe my favorite one
but I go back and forth on the franchise
because one part of me is like wow yeah
they keep this the family tree of Katie
yes she's [ __ ] recording everything
that's going on like at a certain point
this woman's life is not all that it
anything but then another part of me is
like I kind of like how they keep tying
it in and get it instead of just getting
a new cast so yeah there's clever stuff
yours man yeah there saw bility though
to keep you coming back for more wanting
to hear more wanting to see more of the
twist yeah like if you were committed to
the Saw franchise you would watch it I
know people who are not into like
torture porn or anything like that they
like this all franchise because the Saw
movies are like cop thrillers with
torture and spooky elements thrown in
and I do got to applaud them you know
for better or for worse
it worked their asses off to tie
together such a long and intricate story
and they do top themselves when it comes
to the [ __ ] grossest I mean for me
the fifth one had the most gross stuff
when he puts his hand in the blade and
splits it down and so now what to me was
the most see a crushed human being like
oh oh and then when they cryin in the
boat a little bit
no don't like that and I but but even
that that franchise like like even late
into that franchise they were still good
interest because 6 to me is one of the
best ones six is great 7 I didn't really
like but you know it does it does honor
the kill factor if that's what you're
there for
and Halloween Halloween has been a
misguided franchise for quite some time
now yeah I mean the thing about
Halloween is like to me anyway I don't
feel like Michael works incredibly well
unless you have Laurie or some kind of
family thing because they when they
brought him back for Halloween for
through you know 7 or less supernatural
at that point yeah they had the whole
man in black they gonna hold vadouvan
isn't a slasher film at that point you
know what was still a slasher it just
they explained how he was able to stay
alive and you know is so many different
waise then they tried to return to form
with age 12 which I kind of like the h2o
I love that about reboot in my zombies
films buddy I really like those I'm not
gonna lie and get ready for those
comment boxes you know I've been dealing
with those comments since 2007 man and
I'm excited for the new and I like those
writers and especially for their work on
the collector in the collection I've got
my fingers crossed
so you know my my balls crossed I don't
know people expect us to grow up your
flow people expect like a [ __ ]
genital joke for me you know and the
pressure to satisfy making I don't wanna
I don't wanna make jokes anymore what
people expected from me and I'm just
sick of it I want to joke about politics
in sociology that is more where my brand
of humor is like George Bush's Bush
Obama's huge black [ __ ] politics Jay
Friday the 13th yeah okay Friday the
13th though you're dealing with
something that early only gets
established that it's pretty
supernatural and we're watching a [ __ ]
ton of movies now words Jason coming
back from hell over and over again or
whatever yeah I mean they they go full
supernatural on part 6 and then like
they have the obligatory installment
where it's not actually Jason but but
yeah they they get pretty loose with the
physicality early on so it's not
something I feel needs to die I mean I
thought the reboot was unnecessary well
it's kind of necessary because Jason X
kind of took it to space Jason it wasn't
pretty wacky I mean I like the the
remake is at worst you know just fits in
among the sequels and it's better than
some of the sequels like it's it's it's
got some silly [ __ ] in it but it's also
got some some fun stuff and some good
kills and I've hot sex in it yeah and I
really like Derek Mears is Jason I just
want to see him in the snow
I like the woman's tits they showed in
the film yeah that was that was the most
that was the funniest sexy and I've ever
seen he was titillating but also very
very funny
titillating yes in some ways I kind of
agree with her number one choice and I
kind of don't Amityville Horror
is a franchise it keeps going but it was
only interesting like with the first
movie that it kind of just started to
stop becoming interest if he seems like
there's
struggling to keep this one fresh and
the best attempt at doing that wasn't
even in a medieval movie it was the
Kandra yeah the con dream just just the
same investigators you know it's
something that I could see why they
might put it as number one because it
doesn't amp up the entertainment factor
like most people don't even earn that
really familiar with this equals
actually yeah it's like I I didn't
realize they'd made 14 I mean I granted
I haven't this isn't a franchise I got
super into but I personally kind of like
the Ryan Reynolds remake I haven't seen
the remake I've heard it said that there
are at least some cool visual flair yeah
I don't think it's that bad okay and I
thought Ryan Reynolds did a pretty good
job you probably did I mean not you for
those comments it's not the worst of the
Platinum Dunes movies and Hitcher and
Freddy Krueger and probably handle that
anyway guys yeah thanks for tuning in to
the channel those from all-time movies
if you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects you can
check out reasons to Gerry over here
check that out in Schenck a Stubbs
podcast and you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram Twitter Buy in Paris
stores
subscriber female hey real rejects I
have huge tits I'm kidding she didn't
say that's not keep up the good work all
of you make me laugh and your reactions
make my day that much better enjoy the
100,000 play butter an award since it is
well-deserved
oh yeah I play with it every day also I
like your channel because usually the
videos you guys react to I would have
never sought if it was not because of
you guys that's cool turn people on
stuff again great job and love you all
peace if I do get a shout out I like to
be referred to my youtube name rain
fires now and snow Oh rain fire snow and
earth and well rain fires rain fire snow
and earth now ok ok rain fire snow and
earth and what was the last one ether
look look lady why snow why is your name
so complicated it's like a weird list of
very specific element I just want to
tell you I'm glad that you are a
subscriber I know that rain fire snow
and the earth refers to the orgasmic
experience that you have when you know
you watch this channel specifically me
or maybe it's like the post office like
rain sleet snow or hail you're changing
the joke and I was going somewhere about
that okay just hold on one second you
know what happened yes I'm gonna play
with keys okay you're doing it more so
rain fire snow okay so rain refers to
the watery vagina she gets when she gets
wet you know fires went like oh [ __ ] so
then she starts fingering herself and
snow
yes she's thinking of the white jizz
going on her and earth this it's you
know [ __ ] on dirt I'm really glad I
made room for that explain yeah next
time don't hurry up I bet she's glad you
guys are YouTube him instead we will
take care